hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play happy wheels
now I've kind of been staying away from
this game but more and more people have
been requesting it I kind of feel like
it's been done by a lot of people but
one of my donators from the 12 hour
livestream personally requested that I
give it a try so I'm it's gonna give it
a try if you like it
that's great tell me in the comments
blah if you don't like it then
definitely tell me in the comments below
because this is just an experiment to
see what you guys like but I I
personally like the game so I'm gonna
give it a try
we're gonna stop with impossible good
luck
I loved old man alright let's see what
we got anything
I've never shied away from big swinging
balls a day in my life here we go it's
all that experience you know you need
good ball handling skills to get far in
life let's actually get that another try
that wasn't so impossible oh God
and there goes I just want to die a few
times if I fall
and about right Walmart right if I go
over them hahaha can't beat my tech
[ __ ] now I think my balls went up my
ears okay yeah carrying on to the next
one rap battle okay yeah hold space pad
press up and represents this been a
while since I played any sort of happier
like I said um I've told people before
that I played happy wheels way back when
it was first released because the guy
who made it total jerk total jerk face
he made this game called divine
intervention and I love that game haha
yeah hello whoa I didn't that wasn't a
good dollars and a good sound I would
probably not cuz I'm okay haha it's
amazing what people can make you are
ruining happy wheels me stop rate five
restart you will be out of the box if
you say so it must be like oh I didn't
log in to vote okay I guess I won't know
what happens in there level editor now
you can do your own adventure in level
editor okay welcome to level editor
whoops
hahahaha okay I know the white floaty
technique okay no I don't never mind
how's the life whoa hey where you doing
with that excuse me I need to okay here
we go this doesn't seem so bad
what the hell ah yeah oh oh floated like
a boss that was the bike the bike trick
I I know that long
best there ever ever was most epic a
ball jump o my ball handling skills are
gonna come into play again
hello okay all right cool
what the hell um go me Oh what oh hello
oh no no Kevin okay all right what I'm
I'm extreme apparently what what the
hell is going on what how what what am i
doing
oh my legendary how I started playing
fight but you're really boosting my ego
I like that a lot
I like it a lot but I don't know why
you're doing these things what okay all
right I'm a lack of balls
Oh Oh No good ball let go of the ball
come on man it's not worth it it ain't
worth it it's not worth it really
oh there we go no if I was doing
something impressive there or not
it's it made me feel like I was like on
it made me feel like I was the most
talented player in the world spike ball
oh this looks good
go go go oh sorry excuse me sorry were
you dancing there I'm sorry
oh you're yawning okay come on sorry
about your kids
yeah that's a shame I regret it push
don't tell me what to do I'll do what
you say fine
Oh God it's been a while
not those two aren't for me that though
that memory test
try to remember code past whoa okay up
for the no I'm not
my memory is atrocious oh I'm ready
what's the code so god too many numbers
so I know no that's not right one this
is the first one who's this one yes yeah
okay too many numbers it's too many
numbers
I can't do this too much better oh okay
okay okay I think I can do that
Oh smash the first glass I did it did I
did I did it I'm good at this I'm like
the best first hammer time I'm like the
greatest there ever was Oh what oh okay
oh oh yeah you little douche God or what
that's irresponsible yes dies yeah I
level it oh I missed you time mom I
didn't want to break it
there we go give me fatty
Wow
oh man is seriously it's been a long
time I played this game back back when I
played it I remember the first please
rate I can't I'm not logged in I
probably should but we should make it an
account or something just cuz these are
really good like these are unbelievably
creative
I mean it's and these are just made in
the past week I can't believe it there
there's so much content out there okay
spring stare okay can the old guy ran it
this is not wheelchair accessible oh
okay here we go
no I'm going back with them yeah this is
why I love the wheelchair guy I think I
hit a wall or something here we go here
we go
I exploded why why did I explode Boing
oh damn that hurt oh hello
okay ah no not that way okay don't go up
in here again damn it ah sweet backflip
grandpa runs let Oh got your feet what's
this honey love them I don't need your
stairs
I'm Way too skilled in this yeah
like a bow yeah
back I used to play the grandpa
exclusively just because I was so good
and also irresponsible dad because I was
able to get that rapid tap fly connected
don't move
oh it's one of these I've seen these
before okay bring it on den hurt Oh
narrowly avoided oh it's almost as if
this is planned orchestrated even whoa
oh that wasn't supposed to happen
Oh II think you impale my heart ow
no it still hurts oh no it's on my dick
how did I've never understood I am thank
you very much I've never understood how
people make these I mean the trial and
error alone must be ridiculous I'm not
moving
yeah okay
oh they're finally in the can now so
anyone's gonna get in there oh oh not
again why it's sitting I don't think
he's dancing my friend uh-huh and you
finished him off good cuz after all that
I'm be sure that I don't even think that
he would want to live please stop these
is that the same one no I've seen that
before I've seen that before City flight
okay grab the inner circle on one serve
no come no I dare you I got it okay whee
whoa
okey-dokey good thing I got my helmet
okay is it another one if I don't move
oh that hurt a lot but it's okay I've
had worse I think
Oh my other leg dink oh the second I'm
gonna do a bomb sounds like a bomb okay
I mean it's just amazing what people are
able to create I can see the appeal of
this game I really can
I'll tie down indeed my friend I kind of
you know I wish I kind of like more than
these I won't give these too many a try
because you know I like oh hello I might
be at the end here about to smash Oh
loaded yeah I don't like those too much
because I like actually doing stuff I
mean they're cool and all they're like
roller coasters in tutorial I don't
watch our tutorial this is what I want
yes you're responsible mom is that a new
one survived the carnage okay I'm moving
down I think I'm doing that not exactly
sure I think I died a long time ago okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna step out of that one
because my computer apparently can't
handle it police chase okay here we go
okay alright I'm okay flying epic skills
I'm oh I know
sorry kid yeah I'm just using you as a
human shield anyway so I'm getting away
oh my oh it didn't hurt ah thank you
ow okay okay wait no I don't think so
okay all right I'll try another one
it's tea here Tobuscus act out for me
either
are you I'll try not to play things that
aren't meant for me okay here we go oh
really
I don't have much experience with the
Pogo man come on oh I know I'm gonna let
off somehow here but come on I knew it I
predicted it my legs
come right off Oh who's the best there
ever was at these games I am who swore
oh I never played a sword job before
hello baby oh how you doing good job
I you shut up man I didn't see your
taunt there oh yeah you're you just wait
hmm no give me a sword no damn it I want
a sword can I please ha ha ha yeah I
didn't hear a bit okay good
huh good night wait hang on Oh arms two
arms two huge can't reach face Daniel
baby
Daniel baby damn you baby I'm gonna get
you good okay apparently I'm good at
every other thing besides the story okay
all right okay let me just talk yeah
okay I got time for one more
actually no I don't know damn it don't
actually having fun with this okay so
let me know what you think if you like
this you know I don't know I don't know
you know I had lots of fun there because
obviously it's a great game otherwise
people wouldn't watch it if it wasn't
fun but either way let me know in the
comments below if you don't like it hey
tell me I want your opinion anywhere and
if people say they don't like it please
don't downvote there well they're coming
if they don't like it I can perfectly
understand this is just a test to see if
this is something that be
one so if you do that's great if you
don't that's great too so thank you so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye